there's a lot of discussion about quiet
quitting well quite quitting as a
concept is not very new we used to just
call it engagement or disengagement it's
when people just disengage from their
jobs that the thing that I think is
funny about quiet quitting is quiet
quitting is a term that management uses
to describe that their people their
their their staffs are disengaging from
their work they're quiet quitting
however when management talks about how
they're disengaging they talk about
finding work-life balance so I think you
know if we're less judgy about it
it's about everybody struggling to find
that balance between their personal
lives who they want to be what they want
to do and their work and it's hard and I
would prefer that instead of people
disengaging they have difficult
conversations say hey I'm really
struggling to find the balance of work
and I don't want to just disengage I
don't want to be one of the quiet
quitters I want to find out how I can do
this and feel good about myself and uh
and you can still feel good about me